il y a une nouvelle puissance mondiale
[Musique]
va tomber
Je pense que nous sommes vulnérables
et bienvenus pour découvrir
obtenir des billets tenant maintenant des batteurs Le public du 11 novembre
[Musique]
a adopté wakanda et
la panthère noire
et la conversation avec il savait exactement quelle était
l'histoire quoi  ces images signifiaient pour le
monde que
nous avons tous subi une perte incroyable lorsque
nous avons perdu Chadwick Chad était vraiment notre
partenaire artistique Je passerais du temps avec
lui juste lui et moi parlant de l'endroit où nous
voulons voir l'histoire aller à quel point il
admirait les autres personnages  et les
acteurs qui les ont dépeints
et le récit de cette histoire, vous avez
tous pu l'honorer ensemble, c'était
vraiment émouvant de revenir à wakanda
et pour nous de pouvoir le faire avec un
sens de la célébration,
il se passe tellement de choses dans ce
film c'est incroyable tant de nouveaux
personnages à explorer juste en voyant à nouveau le
monde de wakanda et puis maintenant
nous allons dans ce tout nouveau monde
sous
l'eau le nom où c'était un personnage que nous
étions vraiment excité  d pour dépeindre dans le
film sans doute l'un des plus anciens
personnages de bande dessinée de leur âge l'
opportunité de jouer un personnage comme
celui-ci c'est un rêve il est le roi d'une
civilisation sous-marine appelée talukan
il est considéré comme un Dieu vivant
j'ai besoin de savoir si wakanda  est un allié ou
un ennemi,
le niveau de soin créé pour cette histoire
est stupéfiant et nous avons donc tous eu l'
impression de lui donner tout ce que
nous avons et plus encore, je suis tellement reconnaissant
et béni d'en faire partie
les acteurs étaient remplis d'émotion et de
passion je suis la reine de la nation la plus puissante
et toute ma famille est partie
ensemble nous avons fini par utiliser ces
sentiments pour créer quelque chose de vraiment
spécial
l'action et l'aventure avec les
enjeux émotionnels si élevés que des choses se
passent de haut en bas et  partout,
je suis tellement excité à l'idée que le monde
puisse à nouveau puiser dans wakanda
comment chaque personnage relève de nouveaux
défis
et je suis ravi que nous honorions Chad
ouais, il voudrait que nous inspirions simplement
le  monde
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]